لقد فعلت القليل من المرشح
لا يسعني أن أرى النهاية
[صفق]
وهو عضو في المكتب السياسي للجنة المركزية لحزب العمال الكوري ونائب رئيس اللجنة المركزية لحزب العمال الكوري.
وهو عضو في المكتب السياسي للجنة المركزية لحزب Jeongpyeong-e ، Dongchigo ، Suyeong ، Dongjin ، Heonnok ، Party.
التاجر المداعب لي جونغ رو الرفيق
يو كوون ، عضو مرشح في المكتب السياسي للجنة المركزية للحزب ورئيس الأركان العامة للجيش الشعبي الكوري.
الرفيق المذاب الأسود
عضو مجلس الدولة للعالم السفلي ، جمهورية كوريا الشعبية الديمقراطية
على الأقل حجمك وخرج أعضاء مأدبة اللجنة المركزية للحزب مرة أخرى.
[صفق]
[موسيقى]
حزب العمال الكوري Johwang مأدبة سياسية عضو لجنة North 20 مثال أخير لـ Din الرفيق Park Bong-ju
في عصر يين والمعلومات ، بمن فيهم الرفيق التنفيذيون للوكالة
تم الانتهاء من
[صفق]
أوه ، على الجانب اللائق 7 استخدام السيارات
تبادلت التهاني مع المسؤولين الذين خرجوا من الحملة.
[صفق]
المديرين التنفيذيين لمؤسسة الدورة الأولى Bongwoo-ryeok
البذرة حقيقية ويونغدو الرفيق يطلب عودة ميونغ من جيل في زيارته الوطنية.
حاولت محوها بقلبي
[صفق]
قطار الازدهار الذي ركبته في الكتاب الآلي لأبحاث التعهد
الجريدة الرسمية للجهات الحكومية المعنية وإلقاء نظرة فاحصة على المهاجرين